These days, shows aren't exactly afraid to
kill off a main character or two — especially
if it serves the story, or the show gets a
little extra social media attention in the
process.
Here is a spoiler filled look at some TV character
deaths on major shows in 2019 that were unthinkable…
but still totally happened.
Game of Thrones wrapped up a number of character
arcs in its eighth season the way Game of
Thrones likes to do: with a grisly on-screen
death.
The Battle of Winterfell was an event that
the series has long been building up to, and
promised an absolute resolution to one of
the show's biggest storylines.
After all, how could the show's various groups
and families vie for the Iron Throne if they
couldn't fight off the Night King and the
massive undead army under his control?
In the end, the army of the living seemed
helpless to stop it all, save for the lucky
intervention of a certain assassin.
"What do we say to the God of Death?"
"Not today."
And so the Night King's reign was brought
to a swift end by Arya Stark and her Valyrian
steel dagger — instantly destroying every
last undead soldier in the process.
While Gotham serves as a prequel series to
the well-established events of the Batman
comics and movies, the show easily grew into
its own over the course of five seasons.
It also deviated a fair bit from its source
material, delivering the occasional surprise
plot twist that didn't quite match up with
what Batman fans might have expected to happen.
A year ago, Tabitha felt the wrath of Oswald
Cobblepot, also known as the Penguin, in his
convoluted revenge plot over the death of
his mother.
Butch, once dead and resurrected as the grotesque
Solomon Grundy, struck up a tender relationship
with Tabitha, who is otherwise known as Tigress.
The Penguin killed Butch right in front of
Tabitha, adding injury to insult by shooting
her in the leg, swearing to finish her off
someday.
She did manage to survive into Gotham's final
season… but only to fulfill Oswald's prophecy.
At the height of 2019's "No Man's Land" plot
arc, Cobblepot finally stabs and kills poor
Tabitha.
Based on Neil Gaiman's legendary novel, Showtime's
American Gods operates on the conceit that
all the gods anyone has ever believed in are
real, and that they wander around the U.S.
in human form, having been brought to the
new world hundreds of years prior.
And while you might assume that gods are pretty
much unkillable, American Gods doesn't agree.
The show had no qualms, then, in bumping off
Mad Sweeney, an ancient Irish king-turned-bird-turned-six-foot-tall-leprechaun.
In the present day, this scrappy god worked
as muscle for Mr. Wednesday, leader of the
old gods.
Early in the series, however, Mad Sweeney's
magical powers failed when he lost his enchanted
coin.
His luck and good fortune having come to an
end, Sweeney finds himself unable to understand
why his life is falling apart.
Driven to madness, he turns on Shadow Moon,
the show's lead... only for Shadow to stab
him in the heart.
Veep's series finale sees lead character Selina
Meyer become President of the United States
after a series of machinations and manipulations
at her party's national convention.
Selina gets the nomination when she courts
Jonah Ryan's support by making him her running
mate, and gets Buddy Calhoun on board by agreeing
to ban same-sex marriage.
One final roadblock is swiftly overcome after
Meyer frames her loyal assistant Gary for
corruption and has him sent to prison.
"I couldn't have done it without you.  Don't worry I'm not going
anywhere."
The episode then flashes forward to Selina
in the Oval Office, and then to more than
20 years later, when Selina's press secretary
turned CBS News reporter Mike McLintock covers
the ex-president's funeral.
Veep saves one last joke for its put-upon
protagonist, when Mike interrupts and then
ends his coverage of the presidential memorial
to pursue the breaking news that beloved actor
Tom Hanks has died.
It sometimes seemed like the story of Game
of Thrones was really the story of Daenerys
Targaryen — Mother of Dragons, Khaleesi
of the Great Grass Sea, and heir to the Iron
Throne.
Unfortunately, Dany's story came to a very
final end in the show's last episode.
Worn down by her relentless quest for power
and the deaths of her allies, the show's final
chapters saw her succumb to madness and burn
down King's Landing with dragonfire.
This decision, which caused the deaths of
countless innocents, also led to the loss
of support from her lover and nephew Jon Snow,
as well as her chief advisor Tyrion Lannister.
"I freed my brother… and you slaughtered
a city."
After all Daenerys went through in Game of
Thrones over the years, it seems almost cruel
that she came so close to a happy ending.
But any chance of that ended with her descent
into tyranny.
To prevent Daenerys from inflicting her madness
on the rest of the world, Jon Snow stabbed
her to death only feet from the throne she'd
always wanted.
Supergirl killing off Lex Luthor is shocking
largely because he's by far the most famous
rogue in the Superman mythos — and one of
the most notorious villains in superhero fiction
altogether.
With his death, where does Supergirl even
go from there?
Well, in his final moments of life Lex reveals
that Kara Danvers and Supergirl are one and
the same.
It was a tantalizing cliffhanger, as well
as an inglorious end to a season-long arc
for the evil industrialist, politician, and
super-villain.
After all, all he ever really wanted to do
was defeat Superman.
And kill Lois Lane.
And create an evil Supergirl clone.
Is that really so bad?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.